now
so we have almost like the videographer
and the
person in the video
um so we got pearl and ali here so let
me set this up so ally wife
red pill youtuber
uh and a believer in hypergamy is that
fair to say my programming is great okay
just use it to your advantage it's
awesome use it to her advantage be close
to the mic um so she is the person in
the video talking about
um more traditional views on marriage
how she is sort of
subservient to her husband and since
monday did i does i use that word
correctly well i wouldn't say that i'm
subservient i would say that he does so
much for me that it's natural for me to
support his endeavors in life because if
he wins i win boom i like that we're
going to get into that exact topic right
there so since the video which we're
going to play in a second
uh which was on monday i believe because
we met on saturday so this is a day or
so later uh she's been quoted reposted
huffington post world star hip-hop gavin
mcginnis d.l hughley reposted you
but that was thanks to our friend pearl
over here
who basically you discuss what it is to
be a modern woman you take pride in red
pilling women correct and you're very
big on youtube very big on tick tock um
so before we play this video pearl set
this up and then we'll lead to ali
um well i was just in we were in an uber
i think we were going to the conference
maybe
um and i just was thinking that a lot of
girls i think are very confused about
like dating advice and how to get to be
in ally's position
um and like because people will see
she's got a big ring you know she gets
to stay home
she's really into her husband
and i think a lot of women want to be in
that position and so i was thinking oh
this would be a good video if i just if
i start it with the ring and i say show
them the ring see they see what they
want and so they're going to keep
watching and then you know she gives
them the answers in the video
got it so you ready to play this video
so let me just set the tone on this so
essentially is that
is there a title to the video how to be
a housewife what's the title it was how
to get a high value man and be a
housewife um how to get a high value man
and how to be a housewife so basically
just setting this up can we get ready to
play that video so just to set the tone
on this for the gentleman out there by
the way shout out to the valuetainers
out there shout out to all the
entrepreneurs out there we talk about um
a man needs to compete in the
marketplace
be the
way talk about the cme becoming the best
version of yourself as a man i got
nothing wrong with that
talking about focusing on money you know
i'm all about that
muscles looking good i mean i wouldn't
just say
muscles being fit being uh attractive to
women
and game or frame like kind of
understanding your role and and and
not backing down from that so ally's
been calling causing a lot of fem rage
out there on twitter reddit everything
we discussed uh claiming that she's
radicalizing women on her conventional
take on marriage and she's quote unquote
scaring the feminists by convincing
women that it's okay
to rely on men and now they are saying
that she's setting back women 50 years
ali you're setting back women 50 years
so now that the sauce cass audience kind
of understands what this drama is all
about uh by the way we will be taking
your questions throughout the episode
the super chat is live the lovely
natalia will be monitoring that natalia
when you see something good let me know
we're going to start by taking questions
in about 10 minutes on the other side of
these videos and then at the end of the
show stick around because these lovely
ladies will be answering your questions
with that being said let's see this
video that set the internet ablaze make
sure the volume's up please
okay ally show me your ring oh here now
tell me what you do for a living
oh i love my husband
and how did you how did you get that
awesome job
well
i became a better human being
and i became feminine and also shocking
submissive so
that was the secret so what are your
tips to women that want to be a
housewife
to embrace it it's an actual job you
just can't get it in the public or
private sector like you need you need a
man to hire you for it but that's okay
because if you think about it you submit
to your boss who makes you clean stupid
shelves at your retail job right like
wouldn't it be better if you were
cleaning your own shelves at home you
know what i mean and your in your boss
wants to sleep with you in a good way in
a good way
and where where do you meet these men
well i think women should work for the
men that they want to pursue i know that
sounds crazy but it's really easy so if
you think about it like you want a
lawyer right so then you should be a
paralegal or if you want a dentist then
you should be a dental hygienist but
these are considered i guess high value
status professions but i think that's a
really good model that not enough women
utilize because women will bully the
woman who is the secretary that married
the doctor okay but who has the last
laugh like her in her mcmansion with her
husband who's high and the babies like
that's that's who has last laugh so
boom so that was the video that set
things off by the way that was on
pearl's instagram or tik tok just pearly
things
um
comments blew up there was a couple more
videos let's play that and then we're
gonna open up for discussion so they
that was the viral video and then
a lot of ladies said or the comments
were not exactly nice the most of them i
assume right uh and one said
this is heartbreakingly sad so ali had a
response to that go ahead
the women that are saying this is
heartbreakingly sad
i mean i don't know
i get my back blown out regularly i am
fully paid for survival i have my own
autonomy i also do my own work so like i
just don't see what's wrong with my
situation but they can ask themselves
why they're single if they want
oh the single how do you feel about the
woman
all right and then there's one more and
then we'll get to the discussion uh the
response to my husband is not my boss
can we play that one
ally what do you like what do you say to
the women that say my husband isn't my
boss there is no need to be submissive
you're a team
i understand where they're coming from
but these same women don't understand
that oftentimes they'll put their
husbands on the back burner for like an
actual boss in real life that they have
to submit to and they constantly ask
their husbands to modify their lives for
that meanwhile the dude is forgotten
he's absolutely sexless and she's
feeding him out of the microwave that's
the problem if you can work and love
your man equally you want to talk about
equalism right if you can do that then
good but most women can't most women
can't even push the power button on an
air fryer
all right what do you say to the women
okay cool so ally
yes um how has your life changed since
these viral videos like what kind of
response you're getting to this because
i think your whole idea is here find a
high value man be submissive help him
and then create the happy life happy
marriage you want do i got that correct
i would say that's correct i just want
women to be able to marry the men that
they want and then to be able to stay
married because i think that's the
hardest part is maintaining attraction
but if you can get the guy of your
dreams then you should be fine but i
don't think my life has changed much
other than my message is out there i
knew it would get out there in some way
shape or form i just didn't think it was
going to be in the back of an uber with
one of my friends the content creator
and i didn't think that it'd be so um
so awesome to roast women on the regular
it's it's been a blast yeah so